[Applause]
it is now my great pleasure to introduce
your president Lisi Bollinger president
Bollinger has been president of Colombia
since 2002 he is our first set low
professor of the university a member of
the Columbia Law School faculty and one
of the country's foremost First
Amendment scholars he writes and speaks
frequently about the importance of
global free speech to continued social
progress he also teaches a class each
semester that is open to undergraduates
called the freedom of speech and press
so I'd recommend looking looking into
that as you're registering for classes
president Bollinger is also a prominent
advocate of affirmative action as
president of the University of Michigan
he led the institution's historic
litigation in two Supreme Court cases
Gruder V Bollinger and Gratz V Bollinger
these cases upheld these cases upheld
the importance of diversity as a
compelling justification for affirmative
action in higher education
[Applause]
they were reaffirmed last year in the
court's ruling in Fisher V the
University of Texas
beyond welcoming all of you here um
today this is a very exciting fall for
us at Columbia as well this past spring
we opened the first two buildings on our
new Manhattan ville campus in West
Harlem this project conceived and led by
president Bollinger is a university's
most ambitious expansion in over a
century the first two buildings are the
Jerome L green Science Center and the
Len fest Center for the Arts
Shiva cello Jerome L green is home to
the mortar Mortimer B Zukerman mind
brain behavior Institute where the Len
Fest Center boasts state-of-the-art
performance screening and presentation
speed spaces as well as a new venue for
Columbia's Miriam and Ira D Wallach art
gallery this fall the gallery will host
his second exhibition featuring the
works of Frank Lloyd Wright I encourage
all of you to walk the nine blocks up to
one hundred and twenty-fifth Street and
Broadway to really check that out and
take a look it's an amazing and amazing
space and campus and future of Columbia
speaking of activities that get you
moving beyond walking up nine blocks you
may also have heard that president
Bollinger is an active runner who is
known to maintain an impressive pace if
you're all skeptical about that you are
invited to join him right here on
college walk the morning of Friday
October 13th for his annual 5k fun run
through Riverside Park yes put it on the
calendar
but today he is standing with us here to
welcome you to Columbia so please join
me in welcoming president Bollinger to
the podium
[Applause]
it is a very great pleasure to welcome
you our newest students to Columbia
University in the city of New York we
truly cherish the lifelong enduring
relationship we now begin with you at
this critical time in your lives and
with this celebratory occasion we also
feel a deep connection with your parents
and families for whom we know this is a
very poignant moment we welcome everyone
who is attending this evening I regard
it as a privilege to speak to entering
students which to my good fortune I have
been doing for many years now the
transition from what your life has been
to what it will be from this moment on
could not be more profound not only you
will you be on your own probably for the
first time and bear the primary
responsibility for your life from here
on out but most importantly you are
about to become immersed in a unique and
probably never to be repeated in your
lifetime intellectual environment
completely dedicated to advancing human
knowledge and pursuing truth there
really is nothing like a great
University and I strongly believe that
among the great universities in the
world there is really nothing like
Columbia University
Columbia is made up of an unmatched
array of intellectual talent it is more
diverse in its composition in every
respect and truly believes in the
virtues of diversity it is more
international and global in its
sensitivities and outlook it has a
unique curriculum notably with the core
and it resides in a national and global
capital city and draws every day upon
the riches of that special urban
environment moreover I would also say
that this is the right moment to be at
Columbia the fundamentals of great
scholarship and teaching are thriving
but there are also many enormous ly
exciting initiatives underway and new
experiments taking shape all the time as
Jessica just said there's a new campus
in West Harlem Manhattan Ville that is
just opening the first in over a century
as she said with the master plan and the
first buildings by the famous architect
Renzo Piano while you are here the new
campus will become populated with
thousands of students faculty and staff
you should visit the new and acclaimed
show at the Wallach Art Gallery in the
Len fest Center for the Arts which has
an Features major artists from Upper
Manhattan we also have an evolving set
of network of global centers spread all
across the world that are helping our
faculty and our students experience
firsthand and to study the phenomena of
globalization we have new university
initiatives in data science precision
medicine and globalization and last
spring we announced the major venture
called Columbia World projects which is
currently being designed to help make
Columbia the home
for bringing academic knowledge and
capacities together with outside
partners ranging from government to
institutions of civil society to help
solves significant world problems you
will hear much about this in the coming
weeks and months including several
opening projects these are all just a
few of the activities that may attract
and engage your interest while you're
here I can assure you that there is
enough here going on at Columbia to make
you as breathless as the city itself
which leads me to a comment about you
personally it is easy very easy in fact
to feel utterly overwhelmed by all of
this your studies happenings at the
University and the city it is
exhilarating but it can also be
stressful and highly so please know two
things first we all feel the intensity
of life here more or less you are not
alone and second and most of all we are
here to help from friends the faculty to
professional staff we all have a role to
play in helping one another work through
issues no matter how large or how small
and to get the most out of this
extraordinary experiences offered here
so let us help everyone is easily
reachable
including me so do reach out and we
promise you will we will respond just a
moment ago I spoke about the privilege
of welcoming new students it is a time
to think about and speak to the
combination of a student's new life in a
university and its relation to the great
issues of the day there are of course
always critically important issues on
the horizon and drawing attention to
them can help one see one's education in
a larger context
but I have to say that this moment feels
different
more portentous more fraught with basic
uncertainties about basic matters than
at any recent time I can remember this
is true both in the United States and
across the world as authoritarian
regimes and attitudes are on the rise
and democracies and multilateralism
among nations appear to be in decline
all this seems to have come on suddenly
and our lack of preparation is revealed
as we experience one shock after another
I do not wish to be political or
partisan here the university as such
must remain a neutral institution on
matters of political debate generally
speaking we have no official university
position on trade on tax or on health
policies but this does not mean that the
university has no stake in anything
outside these gates or no legitimate
interest in being a participant in the
society beyond our research and teaching
this is a complex matter to be sure and
beyond the scope of this talk but I
would say this when the university is
faced with the potential breakdown of
the societal conditions that make
possible what we do loss of respect for
facts truth reason or loss of respect
for fundamental values such as freedom
of speech and press and the rule of law
or the loss of respect for the rights of
individuals and groups to be protected
against invidious discrimination then
the university has both the right and
the responsibility to speak out and even
to
as both the right and the responsibility
to speak out and even to act to bring
about change the recent highly
disturbing events in Charlottesville
Virginia and at the University of
Virginia and the subsequent
characterization of those events by the
administration are among the most recent
episodes indicating this breakdown
there is no question extremist groups in
America and elsewhere are feeling
empowered and this has only added to
that dangerous sense of empowerment many
citizens and groups among us are
experiencing a greater sense of
vulnerability these days because of
verbal attacks because of new policies
such as those regarding immigration and
because of silences when hatred and
Prejudice manifest itself from the
standpoint of freedom of speech there is
a slow process of degradation happening
the First Amendment is relatively young
having only been formulated as we know
it today over the past century beginning
about 50 years ago the Supreme Court in
a series of decisions establish a degree
of protection for speech beyond any seen
before or sentence in any society so
with some conditions speech of the Klan
of neo-nazis and of white supremacists
is protected even though their messages
are evil this posture is not
self-evidently right
it is certainly contestable but it is
one born of painful experience and one
around which there has emerged a
supportive consensus from both the
liberal and conservative wings of the
American political and legal system
there are many rationales supporting
this approach
for me it is a remarkable effort by the
nation one widely praised and
influential around the world to practice
extraordinary tolerance in order to
highlight and to address a broad need
across all social interactions to be
more open to differences than we are
naturally inclined to be but whatever
the rationale the entire system we have
built up over a century critically
depends upon judges and leaders
condemning the content of the speech at
the same time we insist on protecting or
tolerating it
any ambiguity about how the society
thinks about these messages undermines
what is supposed to be an act of
toleration of Magna minute anonymity not
respect until now
such condemnation has always occurred
the point is that there are many ways in
which this most recent episode in
Charlottesville threatens core values
and systems in the nation now the
important question for us here tonight
is what does this mean for you as you
enter your studies at Columbia and my
answer to that question is that it makes
you and your education here even more
important more vital to the future of
this future of this country and the
world
than I have felt in a very long time I
hope and expect that you will very
quickly discover that what you are
learning here is not just some
abstractions or theories or ideas about
which great minds long ago have worked
on and worked out and what you and we
can take for granted and move on these
ideas and more importantly the
intellectual process and scholarly
temperament by which you will grapple
with these ideas are absolutely and
inherently very much alive and well or
not so well today
in other words what all this means is
that your studies here and now are going
to be as meaningful and as deadly
serious as life ever gets let me close
with a word about freedom of speech on
the campus over the past year especially
there have been many high-profile
instances of speech being denied on
college campuses because the speech was
deemed offense
or because of fear disruptions or even
potential violence or because there was
an wish to avoid controversy here at
Columbia which is a private institution
and therefore not covered by the
constitutional right of free speech the
First Amendment only applies to state
action which includes state but not
private universities but we like most
other colleges and universities have
voluntarily embraced for ourselves the
general framework of First Amendment
jurisprudence it is of course much more
complicated than that statement might
imply but the essential elements are
true and these we like the broader
society have a public forum in which our
students and faculty speak out and about
public issues and often invite outside
speakers in outside speakers have no
right as it were to use our campus
absent and invitation and I would not
hesitate to deny an independent request
to do so under various conditions but
like the First Amendment itself the
scope of ideas that can be expressed
here by students and faculty and invited
guests is very very wide and encompasses
many viewpoints and perspectives that
certainly I at least regard as deeply
offensive dangerous or wrongheaded our
choice has been and is to deal with that
disagreement by means other than
stopping the speech from occurring which
primarily means by accepting our
responsibility to confront speech we
dislike and to state our reasons for
rejecting it it is my
it is my and it is our job to see that
this system is preserved and operates in
the most productive way possible I have
been thinking a great deal about you and
what you might be thinking at this
moment I am confident in this university
just as I am in the nation and our
institutions that we will make it
possible for you to start your lives on
a secure foundation of the values and
practices we both treasure and on which
we have prospered certainly we have much
work to do even if it is more than we
might have expected but it is a genuine
pleasure to think of doing it with you
congratulations on making this
transition in your lives and welcome to
Columbia University
[Applause]